Puerto Rico la isla de Ricky Marty Bad
Bunny Daddy Yankee las piñas coladas
también es conocida por su particular
estatus político porque queridos amigos
esta Isla no es un estado sino un estado
libre asociado de los Estados Unidos de
América un estatus tan particular como
controvertido porque Puerto Rico pese a
estar bajo soberanía norteamericana no
vota por el presidente ni tampoco por
senadores ni congresistas con derecho a
voto pese a ello los puertorriqueños han
ratificado una y otra vez su deseo de
permanecer Dentro de este esquema sin
embargo desde hace algunos años esto
está cambiando y la pregunta es están
listos los puertorriqueños para dar un
siguiente paso hacia dónde se dirige la
también conocida como isla del encanto
una isla que por cierto os tengo que
reconocer que a mí me encanta queridos
amigos amigas En este vídeo vamos a
contar todos los detalles arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Puerto Rico se ha convertido en la mayor
Economía del Caribe y sus estándares de
vida son razonablemente altos
evidentemente formar parte del gigante
norteamericano pues tiene ciertos
beneficios y quizás por eso tanto el
gobierno como los propios isleños
prácticamente nunca se han lanzado a
ninguna Aventura independentista Siempre
han estado muy apegados a su régimen de
estado libre asociado sin embargo los
últimos años no han sido fáciles y el
modelo parece cada vez más agotado y lo
cierto Es que no termina de convencer a
prácticamente nadie y es que al final
los puertorriqueños sí son ciudadanos
estadounidenses pero no tienen
representación real en el congreso no
votan a las autoridades federales y su
justicia no es del todo Autónoma en
cierto modo Puerto Rico sigue siendo una
colonia Quizás por eso los propios
puertorriqueños han dicho basta es
tiempo de avanzar eso sí no para
alejarse de Estados Unidos sino para
integrarse por completo en el gigante
norteamericano y la pregunta es es esto
realmente posible veremos pronto a
Puerto Rico convertido en el estado
número 51 de la unión que podría suponer
Este cambio para la isla queridos amigos
amigas En este vídeo vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes tenemos
que ver un poco de historia para saber
dónde y Cómo comenzó todo vamos con ello
[Música]
Pero antes dejadme que os haga una
pregunta Todos hemos visto gráficos como
este
tras un año terriblemente loco el precio
del gas ha vuelto a los niveles previos
a la Guerra de Ucrania la crisis
energética que amenazó con dejarnos sin
blanca y provocar un montón de apagones
parece haber quedado definitivamente
atrás y la Armagedón energético se ha
evitado pero realmente la crisis ya se
ha terminado y si os dijera que es muy
probable que veamos todavía precios del
gas por las nubes en los próximos meses
no os perdáis el último vídeo de Alberto
en silen hubiera sabido el canal de
información financiera de Motivos con el
que participamos os ayudará a comprender
mejor qué demonios está ocurriendo con
el tema del gas y sobre todo Qué podemos
esperar os dejo el enlace en la
descripción dicho esto Ahora sí volvamos
a Puerto Rico
[Música]
de Madrid a foraker y Jones
durante su segunda travesía el
continente americano Cristóbal Colón se
topó con la isla que hoy todos conocemos
como Puerto Rico su capital San Juan fue
así nombrada Precisamente en honor al
príncipe Juan por aquel entonces
príncipe de Asturias y heredero al Trono
de Castilla y Aragón desde ese momento y
durante más de 400 años la corona
española mantuvo el control de La Isla
hasta que finalmente en el siglo XIX un
enfrentamiento entre España y Estados
Unidos cambió para siempre esta relación
en 1895 estalló la guerra de Cuba en
este conflicto revolucionario sublevados
independentistas se enfrentaron a los
realistas españoles la presión para la
corona era cada vez mayor y su posición
más comprometida para intentar aliviar
la situación y el cada vez más fuerte
sentimiento independentista en 1897
Madrid reconoció como autonomías tanto a
Cuba como a Puerto Rico sin embargo no
Fue suficiente Y además la ayuda del Tío
Sam terminó estando a favor de los
sublevados finalmente un choque político
militar entre España y Estados Unidos en
1898 terminó con la estrepitosa derrota
del viejo imperio el acuerdo de paz
alcanzado estableció que Cuba quedaba
bajo la tutela norteamericana mientras
que Puerto Rico guam y filipinas pasaron
a ser directamente dependencias
coloniales de Estados Unidos
por primera vez Estados Unidos demostró
no sólo su fuerza sino sobre todo su
estatus de potencia y su capacidad de
intervenir en el exterior para limitar
la influencia europea en la región
sin embargo pese a ello no estaba del
todo claro cuál sería su relación con
estos nuevos territorios que ahora Tenía
Bajo su control digamos que en
Washington pues no quería emular el
viejo esquema colonial del imperio
español o el Imperio británico lo que a
ver tiene sentido Al fin y al cabo este
país nació luchando contra el propio
concepto de Colonia Pues bien fue
Entonces cuando en el año 1900 el
entonces senador de Ohio josepher lideró
la redacción y aprobación de una ley
bautizada con su propio apellido la ley
foraker una ley que estableció el nuevo
esquema político que se aplicaría desde
ese momento en Puerto Rico por ejemplo
esta ley determinó que el propio
presidente de los Estados Unidos
nombraría por cuatro años a un
gobernador el cual debería gobernar
junto a un consejo Ejecutivo en el que
como mínimo de sus 11 miembros 5
tendrían que ser puertorriqueños
[Música]
de forma simultánea comenzó a funcionar
en la isla una pequeña cámara de
delegados locales formada por 35
miembros Escogidos por la población
local por su parte para gestionar el
sistema judicial de La Isla se creó la
corte de distrito de los Estados Unidos
para Puerto Rico y se estableció el
recurso de apelación ante la Corte
Suprema de Estados Unidos Asimismo y
pese a no ser un estado los
puertorriqueños tendrían la posibilidad
de elegir un comisionado residente el
cual tendría voz pero no voto en la
cámara de representantes de los Estados
Unidos
[Música]
La Apuesta se redoblaría apenas 17 años
más tarde
[Música]
en 1917 la ley John safrost lubricada
por el entonces presidente Wilson dio un
golpe en la mesa con su Artículo 5 y que
decía este artículo Pues fijaos todos
los ciudadanos de Puerto Rico y todos
los nativos de Puerto Rico que estaban
temporalmente ausentes de La Isla el 11
de abril de 1899 y hayan regresado
después y estén recibiendo
permanentemente en dicha isla y no sean
ciudadanos de ningún país extranjero se
declaran por la presente ciudadanos de
los Estados Unidos y serán considerados
y tenidos como tales ley Jones
1917 de golpe y porrazo se hizo algo muy
pero que muy poco habitual en aquella
época reconocer como ciudadanos de los
Estados Unidos a los puertorriqueños un
privilegios sin precedentes los
puertorriqueños no nacían un estado
formal de los Estados Unidos pero pese a
ello gozaban de los mismos derechos por
cierto os habéis fijado En qué año se
aprobó esta ley Pues os digo esto porque
se dice se cuenta que esta iniciativa
tuvo mucho que ver con incrementar la
base de reclutamiento en medio de la
Primera Guerra Mundial Claro que no
podemos saber si ese fue realmente el
argumento clave
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sea como sea la ley John safron también
generó una legislatura bicameral electa
de manera local y mucho más
representativa una cámara que pasó a ser
competente para legislar sobre los
asuntos de La Isla Eso sí tanto el
gobernador de la propia Isla como
incluso llegado el caso el presidente de
Estados Unidos tenían derecho a veto el
caso es que de esta forma en tan solo 17
años Los puertorriqueños accedieron a la
ciudadanía norteamericana y plantaron el
prototipo de su gobierno civil Pero qué
es exactamente esta Isla una colonia o
un territorio subordinado a los Estados
Unidos sí los puertorriqueños son
ciudadanos estadounidenses pero la
relación de su tierra con el resto del
país es bastante pero que bastante
diferente atentos
[Música]
no estado libre asociado
queridos amigos amigas el gobierno de
Puerto Rico continuó siendo elegido
desde el despacho oval hasta 1947 año en
el que la ley 447 del Congreso de los
Estados Unidos estableció la posibilidad
de que el Gobernador isleño por fin
fuese electo por la propia población fue
así como Luis Muñoz Marín se convirtió
en el primer gobernador electo por los
puertorriqueños su gobierno duró nada
más y nada menos que 16 años y fue
absolutamente clave para el estatus de
la isla en 1950 por ejemplo Muñoz Marín
logró acordar con Washington la
aprobación de la ley 600 una ley que le
dio a Puerto Rico la posibilidad de
tener su propia Constitución Estatal tal
y como ya tenían el resto de los estados
de la unión una especie de ley
fundamental que fija la organización del
territorio Pues bien en este texto que
finalmente entró en vigor en 1952 se
establece que Puerto Rico es en sí mismo
una camonwell a Estados Unidos pero al
estar el texto escrito también en
español la traducción habla de estado
libre asociado que es el estatus que aún
mantiene La Isla actualmente
[Música]
esto queridos amigos de visualpolitik
supuso todo un antes y un después a
partir de ese momento la idea del propio
Muñoz Marín es que Puerto Rico tuviera
cada vez más y más autonomía esta que
Vais a ver es esencialmente la idea que
funda El Puerto Rico moderno y que
Define su particular relación con los
Estados Unidos de América fijaos siempre
habrá un aro de autoridad que delegaré
la defensa la legislación inherente a la
común ciudadanía
la legislación es inherente a la moneda
a la común moneda y algunas otras cosas
por ese estilo pero el progreso es que
cada día
según crezca el estado libre asociado
los votos que ustedes y todos los
puertorriqueños emitimos en las urnas
tengan mayor y mayor autoridad sobre la
vida de ustedes todavía de nosotros de
nuestros hijos de todo el pueblo de
Puerto Rico eso sí no todo fue tan
armónico
en 1950 tuvo lugar el grito de Jayuya
una revuelta liderada por sectores
independentistas armados que eso sí
rápidamente fue sofocada por las fuerzas
de seguridad digamos que todo esto del
Estado libre asociado pues no les
acababa de encajar sea como sea en 1952
el presidente Eisenhower dio el visto
bueno para que se celebrara un
plebiscito para conocer la verdadera
voluntad de los puertorriqueños los
comicios se celebraron el 4 de noviembre
de aquel mismo año y queréis saber el
resultado pues ni más ni menos que el
87,8% de los isleños votaron a favor del
nuevo marco constitucional que
establecía el estado libre asociado el
apoyo fue como veis aplastante
absolutamente mayoritario este sería uno
de los tantos referéndums Por cierto
donde los puertorriqueños se han
manifestado a favor de mantener esta
vinculación con Washington Y es que
digamos que casi que podríamos decir que
la segunda mitad del siglo XX fue una
especie de luna de miel entre los
Estados Unidos continentales y la isla
del encanto fijaos
Sánchez Valle El Traficante de armas que
cambió la historia
la segunda mitad del siglo XX fue un
camino lleno de flores para la economía
puertorriqueña en 1950 el Gobierno
Federal aprobó incentivos Fiscales para
las empresas norteamericanas que se
establecieron en la isla lo que generó
una espectacular Boom económico fijaos
la diferencia con el resto de América
Latina construcciones hoteles negocios
nuevas autopistas la economía de Puerto
Rico comenzó a florecer Y por supuesto
eso tuvo importantes implicaciones
sociales la pobreza se redujo y
prácticamente todos los parámetros
mejoraron durante años Puerto Rico fue
considerado todo un éxito y ojo porque
desde que se celebrará en 1952 el primer
referéndum exportorriqueños han sido
convocados a las urnas en seis ocasiones
más para manifestarse acerca del estatus
de soberanía de la propia Isla lo
hicieron en 1967 1993 1998 2012 2017 y
2020 Pues bien en todas estas consultas
ganó la vinculación con Washington pero
lo hizo de formas diferentes
Sí hasta 2012 ganaba el estado libre
asociado a partir de ese año la opción a
favor de convertirse en un estado más en
un estado formal de los Estados Unidos
pasó a ser claramente mayoritaria y la
pregunta es qué provocó semejante salto
Por qué los puertorriqueños dejaron de
repente de estar conformes con su actual
estatus Pues bien para responder a esta
pregunta tenemos que remontarnos hasta
septiembre del año 2008 cuando Luis
Sánchez del Valle Fue capturado en la
isla por tráfico ilegal de armas este
tipo fue acusado simultáneamente por
dicho cargo tanto por la justicia
norteamericana como por la propia
justicia puertorriqueña Entonces el
acusado demandó al Estado de La Isla al
considerar que una persona no podía ser
acusada dos veces por el mismo delito en
una misma jurisdicción enmarcando así el
reconocido caso Puerto Rico versus
Sánchez Valle que fue resuelto en 2015
con un polémico falla la autoridad de
Puerto Rico para enjuiciar personas se
deriva de la delegación que efectuó el
congreso de los Estados Unidos y no en
virtud de una soberanía propia adopción
de una constitución por delegación del
congreso para organizar el gobierno
local en sustitución de gran parte de la
Ley Orgánica vigente Entonces no
representó una cesión de soberanía a
Puerto Rico por el contrario Puerto Rico
no dejó de ser un territorio de los
Estados Unidos doctrina del tribunal
supremo de Puerto Rico y os preguntaréis
qué tiene esto de polémico Pues
básicamente que los tribunales dejaron
Claro que la soberanía de Puerto Rico no
recae en los puertorriqueños sino que
sigue estando en manos de Washington con
el paso de los años esta concepción
junto a problemas económicos que ya os
hemos contado en pasados vídeos hizo que
de repente se disparara la ambición de
querer cambiar el estatus de Puerto Rico
en 2017 por ejemplo la isla se
encontraba prácticamente en quiebra con
una deuda externa superior a los 70.000
millones de dólares De hecho no fue
hasta enero del 2022 cuando una junta de
supervisión financiera designada por el
Gobierno Federal logró reestructurar la
deuda pública con los acreedores Pero
por supuesto Todavía queda mucho por
delante Hasta que el problema se pueda
dar por superado pero sabéis que es lo
más curioso de todo lo más curioso Es
que muchos de los problemas económicos
de Puerto Rico sino la inmensa mayoría
no tienen nada que ver con Zero no un
estado libre asociado hablamos de cosas
como la ley Jones de la marina mercantil
aprobada en 1920 y cada uno y está en
vigor una ley que prohíbe que barcos con
bandera extranjera puedan transportar
mercancías entre dos puertos de los
Estados Unidos Esto hace que trasladar
cosas a y desde Puerto Rico sea algo
carísimo lo que evidentemente la
competitividad en la isla por qué Pues
porque los barcos con bandera y
tripulación de Estados Unidos son
muchísimo más caros de operar además
esta ley hace que los grandes cargueros
internacionales no se puedan detener en
Puerto Rico con lo cual tienen que hacer
un viaje más largo hasta llegar a la
isla imaginaos shanghaitejas Tejas
Puerto Rico y luego hablamos también de
cosas como el salario mínimo los planes
de subsidios federales pero para
entender esto fijaos en este gráfico
como podéis Ver Puerto Rico es mucho más
pobre que el resto de Estados Unidos sin
embargo como tiene que aplicar el mismo
salario mínimo Federal o un nivel
anormalmente alto de prestaciones
sociales para lo que son los parámetros
de La Isla Pues el problema está servido
lo que es asumible para Texas no tiene
por qué serlo de la misma forma para
Puerto Rico digamos que las políticas y
regulaciones federales hacen que a la
hora de la verdad muy poca gente trabaje
en la isla ese es uno de sus principales
problemas Aunque eso sí todo hay que
decirlo las cosas parecen estar
mejorando Gracias a Nuevos incentivos
Fiscales para las empresas que se
instalan en Puerto Rico pero sea como
sea el caso es que ninguno de estos
problemas cambiaría si el Puerto Rico
deja de ser un estado de libre asociado
y se convierte en un estado más incluso
alguno de sus beneficios Fiscales para
empresas e inversores podrían
desaparecer por completo sí ganaría más
integración influencia Y probablemente
inversiones de gobierno pero por el
camino se dejaría otras muchas cosas sea
como sea esta opción la de convertirse
en un estado más es la gran preferida
por los puertorriqueños fijaos
[Música]
el estatus que pasó de moda
en 2020 Puerto Rico realizó un nuevo
referéndum Pero esta vez ya ni el estado
libre asociado ni la independencia eran
una opción La pregunta era mucho más
clara debe Puerto Rico ser admitido
inmediatamente dentro de la unión como
un estado ésta queridos amigos es
exactamente la pregunta que se hizo en
aquella consulta Pues bien Él sí obtuvo
más del 50% de los votos lo que le dio
el gobierno de La Isla a la fuerza
suficiente como para hacer presión en
Washington una campaña que hoy por hoy
lideral actual gobernador de La Isla
Pedro pierlusini una campaña que
requiere sin embargo superar un
complicadísimo circuito legislativo por
ejemplo la cámara de representantes
tiene que aprobar una ley que habilite
la realización de un referéndum
vinculante para el Gobierno Federal es
decir una elección que no solo sirva
para que los ciudadanos pues puedan
manifestar su opinión como han sido
hasta ahora sino que tenga consecuencias
jurídicas y políticas que permitan que
el presidente de Estados Unidos pueda
terminar firmando la incorporación del
nuevo estado Pues bien en diciembre del
2022 con 233 votos a favor y 191 en
contra sorprendentemente la cámara baja
logró sancionar el proyecto cameal 83-93
se cumplió así el primer paso pero aún
queda el senado Y eso
amigos amigas No es precisamente coser y
cantar porque Pues básicamente porque
Puerto Rico es un territorio
políticamente muy demócrata
[Música]
es decir que muchos republicanos pues
tienen miedo a que les vuelva a ocurrir
lo que ya les pasó con Hawaii que Puerto
Rico se convierta en un feudo demócrata
que condicione la mayoría de las cámaras
sobre todo Claro está en el nada
proporcional senado donde todos los
estados con independencia de su tamaño o
población tienen dos representantes
tenemos que ir senador a senador y
senadora por senadora explicándoles por
qué es justo que se le dé la igualdad de
derechos a los ciudadanos americanos que
Residen en Puerto Rico también tenemos
que explicarles que Puerto Rico es
diverso que tampoco deben pensar los
senadores republicanos que si Puerto
Rico se convierte en un estado
automáticamente eso significa que habrá
dos senadores y cuatro congresistas
demócratas Pedro pierluisi gobernador de
Puerto Rico no sé amigos parece
complicado pero quién sabe en cualquier
caso el gobierno puertorriqueño ha
fijado ya el día 5 de noviembre del 2023
como la fecha para realizar un nuevo
referéndum esperando que para entonces
pues el senado ya haya dado luz verde y
estos comicios puedan ser el paso
definitivo para convertirse en la
estrella 51 del pabellón norteamericano
O al menos en el estado 51 porque la
bandera Parece que ya no cambiará más Y
bueno ya veremos Qué impacto tiene entre
los puertorriqueños y el legislativo les
vuelve a cerrar las puertas pero de
momento turno para ti crees que Puerto
Rico tiene que convertirse en un nuevo
estado Qué beneficios tendría esta
opción Qué te parece la figura del
Estado libre asociado déjanos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios y si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle a like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik y también echarle un
vistazo al vídeo de Alberto en si lo
hubiera sabido Ah y si nos quiere seguir
en nuestra nueva newsletter entra en not
news.com Muchas gracias una vez más por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]